the largest group of people so far all
nevadans aged
16 and older will become eligible to
receive the shot
so how are people here in las vegas
feeling about it 8 news 9 reporter
madison kimbrough joins us live at one
of our valley's main vaccination sites
the las vegas convention center to
explain
madison
sasha we talked to several people today
all very happy that eligibility is
expanding
but to them many of them are not ready
to get the vaccine themselves they say
they're not quite ready to take that
step
and they're going to wait it out i'm
terrified
of so i won't be getting until i need to
but if it comes down to i'm not going to
i'm not going to fight it if it's a
requirement
covid 19 vaccine eligibility is
expanding in nevada
and starting tomorrow those 16 and older
can get their first shot
nevada's test positivity rate continues
on a downward spiral
as more nevadans get the covid vaccine
health officials hope the number of
cases will continue to drop
while this is positive news in the fight
against kovid some people we spoke to
today say they're just not ready for
their covet shot quite yet
i think it's a it's a personal choice i
think if you want to get it i mean you
know to me if you
for me i'm not going to get it because i
feel like
i had it i have the immunities like my
children they're 18
20 and 22 the older ones so you know if
they want to get it i'm
i support that i am one of those people
that is not going to get the vaccine
until i'm forced to i'm not going to
fight it if they say i have to travel
but i'm not really ready for it i
totally respect everybody who wants to
get it
but i don't want people to judge me
because i don't and say that i'm not
you know keeping other people safe on
the other hand there are those that are
ready
and excited for their opportunity i
think it's going to be great because
we have to control this pandemic as soon
as i can i just got to go get and get it
i work in hotels
so right now you know getting our
employees vaccinated me myself
trying to get vaccinated as soon as
possible just to have everything go back
to norm
i should get vaccinated within this
couple weeks as for the lines expected
this week the southern nevada health
district says they are prepared for the
influx of people
as their online appointment system has
been running smoothly for several weeks
now
and all appointments can be made online
just head to our website on our home
page
and you can see that it's going to say
envy eligibility expands that's where
you need to click to find the link to
make your appointment
reporting live from the convention
center madison kimbrough 8 news now